[Music]
hello there fortnite has hundreds of
pickaxes to choose from from the sleek
and minimal to the over-the-top reactive
beacons of light that help us stand out
from everyone else in the lobby today we
are looking at the history of fortnite
harvesting tools please tell me which
pickaxe you main in the comments and
think about subscribing because i'd
really like to get to 2 million subs
please
back when it all began in 2017 we had no
choices to make at all we were given a
randomized soldier and every one of us
had the same trusty default pickaxe it
wasn't much but it did the job and five
years later it's now a cult classic the
first time we had the chance to buy a
pickaxe it was during the first ever
fort nightmares the reaper a scythe like
the one used by the grim reaper himself
this became the most sought after
pickaxe for the first year of fortnite
but that quickly changed when it came
back to the shop in 2018. the sound was
the real draw oh it's nice back then
players weren't used to dropping money
on cosmetic items but holy heck that
changed and a nice reminder now to use
code adamaru for all your purchasing
needs
that season also saw a save the world
inspired pickaxe make it over to br the
pink flamingo combining the head of a
shovel with flamingo garden ornaments
tied to a hose i know that sounds random
save the world was all about making
weapons out of random items the standout
og pickaxe is the raiders revenge a fire
axe with a barbed wire pickaxe head if
you have this you may flex on us all
forever
season two brought us the first ever
battle pass containing the first
pickaxes to unlock we had the excalibur
to represent the medieval skins the
pulse axe for the space skins and then
the first animated harvesting tool the
ac dc this pickaxe is still seen
commonly in game almost five years later
it's a classic the most impactful
harvesting tool of season two was the
plunger or to say it correctly
the plunger ninja asked epic to make
more cosmetic items and joked about a
katana mixed with a toilet plunger so
epic made it a real thing and i think
it's great do you own it just remember
the correct way to say plunger the
plunger
[Music]
when season three hit fortnite added so
many pickaxes it was tough to keep up
with but the one which was most
celebrated is the trusty number two a
pencil that's it just a pencil this was
the first easter egg pickaxe as it was a
homage to john wick and his ability to
eliminate enemies using only a pencil
the real john wick finally arrived a few
seasons later but during the first year
of battle royale nothing was official
season 3 introduced more animations for
pickaxes and the first reactive axe was
introduced the rainbow smash a plethora
of colours would glow during each strike
and should you obtain enough limbs the
horn glows too back then comedy pickaxes
were all the rage and the pig squeak was
a favorite amongst content creators
imagine being bludgeoned to death by a
children's toy that sounds like this
or the humanity
season four saw a freaking giant
lollipop pickaxe added and yet another
easter egg this time to wreck it ralph
this one became a humiliation tool just
like the pig squeak other pickaxes
included three superhero tools one for
the fake wonder woman and one for omega
and carbide the real pickaxe made for
flexing this season was the tenderizer a
twitch exclusive pickaxe shaped like a
butcher's meat hammer if you own this
you have the right to flex season five
changed our expectations for pickaxes we
could now use a microphone thanks to the
lead singer set and it became possible
to eliminate players with balloons a
literal axe made of balloons the
embarrassment of being bludgeoned by
that thing was unimaginable playstation
got in on the act with an exclusive
pickaxe which is not great if i'm honest
this was the season which introduced
drift and his rift edge which remains a
much loved harvesting tool years later
but without a doubt the greatest pickaxe
of the season was the crowbar and the
best thing of all it was free to
everyone we unlocked it in a new game
mode years later it's still considered
one of the best pickaxes ever and it was
totally free but were you playing back
then to unlock it
season six arrived and epic noticed the
most used pickaxe was the rainbow smash
so they made a dark variant the thunder
crash it was reactive too but more
emotional it was more emo other axes
which got a lot of attention were the
reckoning an axe that was a stake to
kill vampires and the guiding glow a
pickaxe for little red riding hood to
hunt down wolves it was a weird season a
cool touch is the floating bugs that
gather by the glowing light it's a
really nice touch the big flex pickaxe
of season six the stella axe another
exclusive but this time for anyone who
bought samsung galaxy phone i'm kinda
still gutted i don't own this it's done
beautiful
[Music]
season seven was a season of re-releases
many of the pickaxes that came out this
season had already been here before but
that didn't mean there wasn't some great
new ones too like the abominable axe a
thawing ice hammer with fish trapped
inside still alive by the way flopping
about they're fine in there another free
pickaxe dropped and it was a big deal
marshmallow was about to remind us how
many of his songs we actually know
without realizing and to build up hype
for his coming concert we could unlock
the marshy smasher one of his well-known
beats could be heard every time you
swung the axe and hit something every
single time it was it was loud and it
was obnoxious so it was perfect recently
the axe got a golden update too and edit
style with a regal twist season 8 had
the most pickaxes introduced than ever
before the most unique was the swag
smasher a freaking pirate octopus
guarding a treasure chest what more
could you want well the community said
they wanted less actually the driver
became a sweat item and also a running
meme about the last of us part 2 and
joel's demise
ouch this was the season the star wand
released the thing sweats and wannabe
sweats can't live without i'll buy it
the day i managed to crank a 90 which is
not going to be anytime soon oh and this
was the season save the world founders
received the rose glow axe hugely
underrated in my eyes but i do have a
thing for pink
season 9 changed pickaxes forever
because dual wielding was added the
harmonic axes released and the
floodgates opened tons of axes had new
variations to buy the mema's choice was
the fork and knife another easter egg
referencing a young lady who was trying
to impress her man by playing fork knife
bunker jonesy's ripe rippers were all
the rage that season until the real john
wick arrived with a freaking
sledgehammer the one he used in the
movie to come out of retirement a very
iconic moment season x is here and the
world is destabilizing fast things were
broken this season i thought it was
through design as dimensions were
colliding and random things were
happening on the map yet there were some
issues too the star wand began to hit
people for over 50 damage making it
crazy overpowered thanks to that and the
world cup that made the star ones the
most used pickaxe of the season and for
the next year too people loved it season
x gave us a pickaxe from batman and
another playstation exclusive too but
nothing could really overthrow the star
wand oh another nice thing about save
the world the axis from that mode came
into battle royale
it's now chapter 2 and one of the
longest seasons in history so much so it
had a new record for pickaxes released
the big thing this season was the merry
mint pickaxe a code was needed to grab
this bad boy and if you had it you felt
amazing this season had so many top
quality items to choose from star wars
skins were brought in rey's quarter
staff kylo ren's scythe and the riot
baton jinji was given dual-wielding
gingerbread axes and three versions of
the strikers released the molten the
dark and the shadow and then harley
quinn and the gotham set arrived the
punchline and the harley hitter would go
on to be huge especially the harley
hitter which was embraced by the sweats
and the wannabe pros my favorite pickaxe
this season was elfisto the storm king's
fist i still don't know why people don't
use this axe it's a massive fist what
more could you want
season 2 chapter 2 saw the debut of the
cyblade a marvel crossover axe that was
a one-handed energy spike this was one
loved by everyone sweats casuals and
marvel fans alike something genuinely
unique and hey it's pink who doesn't
love pink this season saw the acts of
champions released and given to fncs
winners so they could rock it to scare
the living hell out of anyone they faced
or to be targeted by the entire lobby
both happened season two brought us
deadpool but surprisingly his malaton
hammer combo didn't stay in the public
eye for very long at all
[Music]
chapter two season three saw captain
freaking america added with a back bling
that was also a pickaxe this was
revolutionary and started a trend to add
extra details to skins with a back bling
and harvesting tool that matched the
double wrenches became a hit this season
as double-handed axes became more common
than standard pickaxes oh and epic put
grain the gnome on a stick something for
us map change peeps
[Music]
season four was marvel central each hero
added had their own harvesting tool some
were more unique than others let's say
like thor's hammer meow meow only he
could wield it but if you knew about the
legend of steve rogers you know that he
could actually pick it up too a great
touch of detail the crew pack became a
big deal this season and one of the
first pickaxes released was the cosmic
llamacorn basically a re-skinned rainbow
smash for the third time with elements
of the galaxy axe storm's hand of
lightning and iron man's energy blade
were widely celebrated too and season
four was the time they brought back the
original fortnite pickaxe all the
nostalgia and that one is still used to
this day
chapter two season five will go down in
history as the season which popularized
one-handed pickaxes what i mean by this
is they're intended for two hands yet we
wield them with one making your
character look like they are crazy
strong we love them and in particular
the leviathan playstation fans have
known about this beast already but many
players had never seen kratos attacks
from 2018. this version of the leviathan
had rune slots from the game which were
set to ice this makes the axe glow with
frost energy and the built-in emote is
one of the most badass things you will
ever see on top of that it's just a good
looking axe gamers sweats and casuals
alike enjoyed it sarah connor's combat
knife arrived this season too a
single-handed weapon with a great detail
when selecting the harvesting tool she
would remove it from her sheave on her
hip i love those kinds of details then
the primal season arrived and this crazy
underused pickaxe released the chain saw
it's a dino skull with a chainsaw inside
why doesn't anyone like this lara croft
brought her climbing axes to the game
for a little more realism and the nuzzle
jet was the wow item from the crew pack
a sci-fi energy jet suspended in place
love it eli from horizon zero dawn
brought her spear and dc crossover
comics gave us batman's grapple axe a
single-handed weapon which was
effectively a re-skin of the star wars
baton a few seasons earlier on to season
seven of chapter two the meme choice of
the season was morty as a hammer it's
weird to anyone who doesn't watch the
show but to those who do watch rick and
morty this is just acceptable when
superman got here for some reason he was
given the biggest pickaxe in history the
solitude striker is an abomination does
anyone genuinely use this
the final season of chapter two saw some
interesting axes added for the memes and
the tryhards the big spoon released milk
splashes became normal and oversized
cutlery was for the cool kids fortnite's
birthday gave us a free pickaxe to work
towards this year with four slices of
cake to represent the years that have
passed which is now something we expect
every year the demon slayer blade became
popular with casual players thanks to
this emote summoning a pickaxe from the
aether fortnight has changed a lot since
2017. we could also unlock a free
pickaxe a rocket league crossover
allowing us to hit people in the face
with a remote controlled car
[Music]
and now it's chapter three we are
approaching the end of season one and so
far we've had a subdued choice the
popularity of harley quinn's baseball
bat has brought us more versions in
chapter three such as a branded
spider-man bat because we all know peter
parker loves to fight crime with a
baseball bat take that grime in fact we
had more free pickaxes to obtain this
season during crimbo merry chrysler we
could pick up the holly hatches and the
mean pickaxe of the season is the snow
plower random but great after all these
years how do you feel about pickaxes
which is the one you pick the most which
is the greatest harvesting tool in the
history of fortnite please let me know
in the comments below and thank you if
you stuck around this long i'm adam
you're awesome here's some legends use
code adamara this week thank you kindly
big kiss i'll see you all next time
you